[Music]
alright thanks for joining everyone
welcome to Ops 2 1 1 continuous
integration and delivery into kubernetes
my name is Justin Brooks I'm the
director of engineering at Sava systems
I've been working there just in
background I've been working there about
eight years I've been the director of
engineering for four Saada as a reseller
for Google cloud platform we help
customers on board onto GCP or transform
their existing GCP applications into
more optimal implementations in this
presentation I'll be going over a little
bit about kubernetes a little bit about
CI CD and our our best practice
recommendations for what we have been
blended for one of our applications for
one of our products called atom okay so
what is continuous integration you guys
probably already have a brief
understanding of what that is but just
to rehash it it involves developers
integrating code as often as possible it
was in a shared repository in the
process around that including automating
building and testing for that
application it allows teams to get
feedback quickly and find issues early
and that it can be extended further
after you've implemented CI into either
something called the team continuous
delivery or continuous deployment where
those changes are automatically deployed
into various environment levels so on
the screen here now we have a sample
application infrastructure on somewhat
something could like to look like that
incorporates kubernetes you'll notice
that the important components here are
the implementation of the container
registry for hosting docker images and
github for your source control
alright so briefly about kubernetes so
at a glance this is sort of the
representation of the architecture of
kubernetes it helps you manage container
clusters supports multi cloud bare metal
environments and supports multiple
container runtimes
there are several also additional
benefits you get out of running gke on
on google cloud including auto scaling
and auto healing
one of the components of kubernetes is
the API server so this is this is
basically how you do all of your
interactions with the kubernetes cluster
and is essentially how the CI tool is
going to interface with the cluster as
well it's an API it's all API centric
it's there's no private API it's just
there's no system only call everything
communicates through the API and it's a
restful type of service so you see we
have an example of that you can actually
see on the bottom right hand side
although you can't really read it the
detailed logs that you get in
stackdriver showing all the API calls
that are being made as part of a
deployment controllers are fundamental
to how kubernetes work it's a piece of
code that watches a kubernetes api and
reacts accordingly
essentially it's code that runs in a
loop listens to the API server and
responds to changes
for example when you want to create a
pod what you really want is to schedule
something in the system scheduler wakes
up in a system determines where it's
going to put put in the pod and it
writes back to the API server the Kouga
then wakes up and orchestrates what we
want to the system so that it's it's all
unified together as part of this process
that's part of the CI CD pipeline so the
nodes the nodes are the the actual
worker machines that run the containers
manage the master components including
services like the container runtime the
Kubla and the COO proxy if you're
running an on-premise environment this
would be a physical machine if you're
running in the cloud it's most likely
going to be a virtual machine the
container runtime has a interface which
actually facilitates plug ability
supporting different types of containers
including docker rkt and others the
couplet is the most prominent controller
which implements the pod and the node
API is to drive the container execution
layer and the coup proxy is a service
abstraction that groups pods under a
common access policy program it programs
the IP table rules to trap access to
service virtual IP s and redirect them
to the appropriate back-end
okay the pods are small groups of
containers and volumes they're tightly
coupled they live and die together as
they're spun up and spun down and they
have shared networking in life
cycle the containers within a pod share
an IP address and they find each other
via localhost now a pod can run as a pod
typically is set up to run just a single
container but it can be it can run
multiple if necessary depending on the
use case deployments are the declarative
updates for the pod so basically you
specify a desired state the deployment
controller then handles the actual
execution of reaching that state
services are an abstraction that defines
the logical set of pods and the policy
by which they are access each pod has an
IP services provide a stable virtual IP
so that even as you scale up and down as
part of your process for auto scaling or
any issues with self-healing it
maintains a single virtual IP that you
can use to access those services and
finally secrets and config map these
hold all the sensitive information such
as passwords o auth tokens etc this is
obviously gonna be a key component of
the CI CD process for maintaining these
secrets that are going to be sure
distribute across each environment they
are there are numerous automatic Secrets
that are created by kubernetes to store
the credentials to access the API
they're base64 encoded and not encrypted
the config Maps are then used to store
the non sensitive information and then
you have it in image pol secrets that
utilize to set container registry
credentials that's going to be crucial
when we talk about the implementation of
the CI CD pipeline and how it interfaces
alright kou control is obviously the
main component main CLI that you're
going to utilize to execute any actions
against the cluster listing pods
applying changes things of that nature
this is this is another key component
that's going to be utilized by our CI
tool as part of the build and for the CI
a CD component for the deployment
alright so now we get into orchestration
tools this is these are key components
of the CI CD process that are utilized
in the actual automation pipeline so DCP
service accounts are going to be crucial
everything he needs to run should be
running through a service account rather
than a user account you'll be managing
those directly typically either within
some form of a deployment management
management solution or in the console or
even via the G cloud CLI deployment
manager is a solution that's that's
typically used Google native around
automating the cloud deployment so it's
so that you have your infrastructure
codified it's repeatable declarative the
templates can also be pulled once
created manually for resource recreation
so you can reuse that across multiple
different services now terraform is
often a common alternative to this
that's also useful they have both have
their drawbacks in this particular
instance we're talking about a GCP
deployment manager implementation all
right for automation we are utilizing
Travis CI there it's basically a hosted
CI tool for for handling all of the
automation all of our scripts are in
there so it handles everything with
downloading everything from downloading
the G cloud SDK setting the appropriate
zone cluster and prostitue project to
deploy to activating a service account
installing the coop control CLI
obviously circle CI is another
alternative cloud bill Jenkins any tool
we are at we actually use a combination
of both Travis and circle in our
implementation for our artifact
repository we're utilizing artifactory
it's a universal artifact repository
it's been around for a while
it supports many software packages
created in any language see ICD
integration with nearly every provider
and hook properties for simple simple
query when you need to access specific
items it handles all of these different
multiple repository types include talker
and PM maven Gradle Debian and generic
repository so those are key those lists
those listed out are key because those
are actually the big components as part
of our kubernetes CI see dat deployment
the generic artifact repository in this
case is utilized for the Android
that allows us to build and test and
publish internally prior to releasing to
the App Store this implementation also
note in this implementation we discussed
potentially utilizing helm in arm
position we do not yet use that but it
is a recommended use case and would be
useful in the future to be hosted in
artifactory okay so the build pipeline
alright so the this is where we talk
about essentially how it's all
orchestrated so the application code in
our particular build pipeline the
application code is decoupled from the
infrastructure code in separate
repositories so we have two different
repositories for each service that we're
deploying the the deployments are
orchestrated on these various
environments or specific containers are
completely again completely
disassociated from the application code
so the process at a really high level
and we'll walk through that deeper later
is that the application code is built
compiled and packaged code is pushed to
the binary repository which houses
binaries of all sorts including the NPM
modules any jars docker images and any
other binaries that might be needed and
then upon deployment the binary is
pulled from the repository and consumed
as part of another build orbit raishin
step or deploy to the appropriate
resource it's fairly modular and
flexible note that we can actually build
an orchestrated deployments across
individual services or across the
environment holistically I'll walk
through that in a bit okay so part of
how artifactory is used on GCP so we
pushed images from the bill obviously
during the build step we create a docker
image that's pushed to artifactory it
can also be pushed to GCR that's google
container repository know that that GCR
implementation is a really good choice
because there's native support within
GAE in the case we are using a private
repository such as we are in this
instance we need to create an image
pulled secrets linked with a secret
config type using that kubernetes IO
docker config JSON
okay next we update the container image
through the pipeline so as I stated
you're essentially seeing on the right
there an image of the source config for
the infrastructure configuration again
in the independent repository so we've
actually we've gone through now we've
created the image it's been tested and
validated and successful we update the
docker image tag in that config finally
we apply the changes to the cluster just
one quick note all of these items are
actually automated through build scripts
I'll show you a little bit what that
looks like when I get to the demo
section but none of this is actually
done by hand okay
now we actually have an overview of the
this sort of cohesive automated test
publish and deploy pipeline so starting
from the top left all of our code is is
hosted in github or whatever repository
you might utilize it works the same way
that then based on a pull request will
lead towards a build on Travis which
then pulls the code builds the
containers any associated artifacts that
are necessary runs the test on a test
environment and publishes those
artifacts to a binary repository in this
case artifactory those containers are
then on the bottom as you can see on the
bottom right they're labeled with the
appropriate version numbers this
implementation we have microservices
approach we have a several different
services that are tagged with all of the
different versions for the multiple
different services with their own
version tags their own environment like
labels and as well as describing the
type of sort the type of code that were
utilizing for that implementation then
Travis then then makes a call to deploy
this to the kubernetes environment which
pulls the containers from that
repository note also a key thing here is
that monitoring is built-in throughout
the entire process through a number of
different sources so we are monitoring
obviously via stackdriver
we are also getting notifications from
github as those pull requests are being
approved and succeeding or failing
similarly on the Travis side and all of
those have hooks and are in our
environment are integrated to notify us
slack channel all that then creates our
full application so you see you know
this is utilize across all of our
different environments for web back and
iOS and Android and so this is a
representation now of basically are
completed infrastructure that I talked
about we would be implementing so you
see you know I'd utilized two shared
services across the multiple clients
pointing to through code a load balancer
to Cooper Nettie's engine in this
instance it's not we're not technically
to go into detail about here but we have
two database types for representing
different different types of data we
also have cloud storage and the the key
factor again here is at the bottom we
have the representation of the binary
repository being artifactory and our
source control of being github okay so
the continuous integration of pipelines
so in this since this is essentially how
we get our code through to the
integration steps all the way to our dev
deployed in our dev environment I'll
walk you through that so essentially we
have our source code in this case I'm
gonna follow the source code path for
our our front-end application so our
application source code is in our master
branch is the pole for that to work then
we have a pull request that's created
it's reviewed by our team it's approved
code is then merged into master with a
new application version that new commit
triggers a build on a master branch in
Travis CI then we see Travis CI making
the call to now successfully build a new
image pushing it into artifactory once
that checks out we move on to the next
stage where it checks out the dev ranch
in the associated paas repository so in
this case the pod repository is that
independent infrastructure repository
we're using to separately from our
application source code and then it
updates a deployment container in image
that the changes to deployment yeah the
deployment yanil configuration are then
committed to the pod depository in the
dev branch
then you see you seated down there we
have the web pod repository the dev
branch hasn't been updated that commit
triggers a new build process a new next
step in the build process which builds
the the branch and Travis CI that that
process is actually the deployment step
so utilizing a combination of G cloud
and the service accounts we mentioned
earlier as well as several different
build scripts that are part of the set
up of that pod it it successfully
deploys the resource configurations to
the kubernetes resource once that done
once that's done the image on on the
kubernetes side the images will then be
pulled into that deployment and rolling
updates are made to the underlying
infrastructure
oops alright so next step is continue
the continuous integration for a single
or multiple container promotion so this
would be if we want to just update again
I'm talking in this instance about a
micro services based environment so if
we wanted to just update a single
service we would follow this step so
here you see we have the backend pod we
have the backend pod for the dev branch
in order to promote to QA in this
instance a pull request open gets
opening it's the QA with a branch that
pull request once approved then updates
a single or multiple image tags and
depending on the configuration we're
choosing in the deployment yeah Mille to
the versions in dev that then it's then
it's reviewed and approved and then in
code is merged into the QA branch once
that happens that triggers a new commit
on that triggers a new build on Travis
CI again running through a similar
process to go through and actually
execute the builds build stages and then
deploy to the cloud environment okay so
this this gives you a better sort of a
representation of how the releases can
be attributed from one environment to
the next so we have multiple different
versions of each service in
Debu 80 and prod we we have an
overarching version for the environment
level that's that's noted at the bottom
in this instance the front end and back
end or different pods altogether they
these pods have a series of containers
that describe the pod so going from one
environment to the next involves kicking
off a CI build process that reaches out
to the deployment Yambol for that
specific environment and applies it on
the appropriate cluster this can be
orchestrated with either different
branches or different folders in this
particular instance we're using the
branch segregation for different
environments alright so this is the
in-depth process around how we do the
continuous integration for environment
to environment promotion so when we want
to take all of these all of these
services from one environment to the
next being promoted from in this
instance key way to UAT
this is that workflow so it starts off
with we actually so in order for this
workflow to work we have a separate
environment repository that stores the
status of each particular environment
again using that branch segregation
methodology so it has a JSON schema
representing each pod and as well as the
underlying containers of that pod that
represents the current version of that
pod in that environment
so this environments repository we look
at it u8 the UAE branch again similar
process as before a pull request is
created from QA 2 uit that pull request
is then approved code is merged into UAT
with the versions from QA and that then
once that happens that new commit
triggers a build on the UAE branch and
Travis CI then in Travis it checks out
the UAE branch in every pod defined
based on that environment JSON
configuration I mentioned every image in
the pod repository UAE branches and
updated to reflect the version that was
mentioned that JSON config for the
represent requisite version of that pod
the changes to each each pods deployment
yell are then committed to the UAE
branch of that repository so it
orchestrates the
those changes across all of the
different repositories for each service
each of these new commits trigger a
build and UAT in the UAE brain at the
pod UAT branch and Travis CI but then
actually again goes to that same process
builds the container makes all the
appropriate configuration to reach ange
request and pushes that through to
kubernetes on its so next just to get
you a little bit of a representation of
what this looks like work I'm gonna
switch to this demo to sort of see
basically what our source repositories
look like so as I mentioned I'll start
with the environment JSON configuration
so as I stated we have an independent
repository called environments within
that we have an environment JSON that
has the the appropriate configuration
values for each for each pod in that
environment so we have a ton of
different pods with a ton of different
containers again we're using this branch
methodology so we switch between dev
prod QA and UTI UAT and those walls will
have different configuration values
based on the respective version that's
being utilized in that environment
similarly the other point to represent
as I stated we do have so we have
separate repositories so our source code
in this case for the web app web
application is all hosted in this single
repository and then we also have pod
configurations again as represented in
the independent repository you'll notice
obviously the source code is where all
the devs are going to do their work the
pod is gonna is in this case managed and
monitored by a headless user that's that
Travis CI users and as I stated that
will then update with the appropriate
image as I represented in that earlier
slide as well with a correct
configuration value another key point to
be aware of all of these as I stated all
of these tasks that I'm representing
that are happening within the CI are all
scripted out in in our application in
this case because we have so many
services they all share similar
configurations and how the CI a process
works and how we plan on utilizing it we
have a common CI
repository that forms the basis for all
the scripts that we utilize across our
application
[Music]